is the babylon 5 project scuppered
before it even started
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so i did a video a few days ago
announcing basically the babylon 5 is
going to return in our screens
and jay michael jaczynski actually hopes
jms from now on because stradinsky is
quite a hard name to say
actually hopes to have it on our screens
in 2022.
now as a lot of my comments stated
just after he tweeted that and tweeted
that he hoped that it would be on our
screens in 2022 it was announced to the
cw the network that is buying the new
babylon 5 series is actually up for sale
so does this ruin all of our plans
almost straight away
well you'll be relieved to hear
no
two days ago on basically wednesday um
jms actually tweeted again basically
said that the script
is finished it has gone to the cw they
have agreed it then he is now just
waiting on that final say-so and he's
hoping for that green light by the end
of the month so we may actually have a
final definite yes or no within only 10
days or so
but i hear you cry the cw sale is still
going ahead so what does that mean well
basically the cw sale is not quite the
same as the problems we're seeing with
mgm sale or like when disney bought fox
it's nothing like as big and nothing
like as complicated the two current
owners warner media and viacom cbs own
50 50 shares in the cw network and they
are selling up at t warner media
are pulling back away from very
expensive media projects and they're
going to concentrate 18 t is going to
concentrate on its core business the
telephone industry
cbs
just wants to back off and they still
want to produce material for the cw but
they don't really want to own the
network anymore to be honest the cw
network has been unprofitable ever since
it was created so moving on and selling
up in this very
difficult few years that we've had makes
perfect sense for them
mark perdowicz the cw current chairman
released a very nice statement to the
financial times basically saying that
these two companies just wanted to move
on and prioritize other projects
so who is in line to buy the cw next
star is a very large company probably
the biggest company you've never heard
of in the media industry it actually
owns the most tv small local tv channels
in all of the united states
and actually is the biggest affiliate
for the cw in the united states at the
moment so already has really strong
links to the cw network
now the plan according to that financial
times is that this nuke on this next
star company will move in and become the
biggest shareholder of the cw it will
effectively take control of the company
but warner media and viacom cbs want to
stay involved they will become minority
shareholders with the agreement to still
produce content for the network
so cbs will still be producing a lot of
the material that we will see on the cw
however next star is taking the reins
now this deal once it's agreed it's
still being negotiated at the moment but
is expected to actually go through by
the summit this year will still have to
be approved by the regulators this is
not going to be a long-winded affair
like it is with
18 months to for disney to buy fox um
at least a year now already probably
again going to be 18 months for mgm to
be bought out by amazon this should be
something that goes through reasonably
quickly as i say the company in question
always has very strong links to the cw
network they already show the network on
most of their stevie stations and it's
just going to be a matter of them taking
the reins
this is not going to be a big monopoly
question it should be reasonably
straightforward and especially
considering that the owners are actually
going to still be involved just becoming
a minor shareholder basically there's
a belief at the moment that actually mgm
for example is having to stop producing
material because it is in like a legal
quagmire but it's actually not really
true it's only an illegal quagmire
because mgm and amazon haven't got an
agreement on how to produce material in
the future
in this case with the cw it should be
very straightforward for the three
parties to agree how to move forward
but the cw in the position that they
have the three parties involved actually
in agreement and actually wanting to
produce some new material because two of
the owners are still going to be
involved in making that material
so this should be pretty straightforward
and wouldn't affect babylon 5's return
it should come back just as planned
but i hear you say how about this
12-month plan that jms has talked about
that he wants it on our screens by
winter this year well just think about
it babylon 5 star trek back in the day
they used to produce 22 episodes every
year
in lots of ways the special effects and
things are much quicker and easier than
they were 20 years ago when jms and star
trek were doing this regularly year in
year out
it's going to be the same name if the cw
and jamis want this to be on our screens
by the end of the year it really
shouldn't be that difficult
they'll start producing and start
filming before even all of the episodes
have been written that's how they always
used to do it and that's what jms is
hoping to do it now so could we have
babylon 5 on our screens by the end of
the year
there is absolutely nothing to say we
can't and we should know within only two
weeks so as soon as this is greenlit and
we are definitely getting the pilot and
i should say if this is only talking
about getting the pilot episode the
pilot episode you need and then the rest
of the series will be greenlit or not at
a later date but to get the pilot we
should know within only two weeks and i
will
so i will tell you as soon as that is
finalized
so guys tell me get on the comments what
do you think for one do you want jms to
produce babylon 5. a lot of people have
said they're very fearful it's going to
just become woke nonsense and they're
really worried that this is just going
to be ruined like so many other shows
have been
i personally don't think jms would let
that happen and i actually think
jim the original babylon 5 series was
pretty woke in itself so please again
get on the comments what do you think do
you agree it was very spiritual and had
lots of um factors that people
considered to be woke in it
and a lot of it wasn't very subtle so
you know for me it was a pretty woke
show and it was one of the reasons why
you know it was so special in the first
place
but also in the last video i told you
what the plan is this is going to be a
hard reboot
nothing is going to be the same we are
not going to see actors brought through
from the original series chances are and
if they are they won't be playing the
same characters anyway
so what do you think about that do you
want to see this as a hard reboot for me
again i think it only makes sense and
i'm really looking forward to seeing
what jms reimagines this brilliant
storyline into
but if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
you can join the channel
for a small charge every month you can
help me produce more contact and become
a sidetracker supporting the channel
if you'd like to join us on facebook you
can also do that the link is in the
description
and please everybody stay safe i'll see
you really soon